una sentencia importante para las
mujeres de benin los legisladores
votaron para legalizar el aborto en las
primeras 12 semanas del embarazo más
tweet trata con tops estoy muy muy
contenta que a partir de ahora podamos
devolver este derecho a la mujer la
autonomía sobre su cuerpo y a decidir
por sí misma es sinde por el mem la
interrupción voluntaria del embarazo ya
estaba autorizada en benin en
condiciones restringidas por ejemplo si
la vida de la madre estaba amenazada por
el embarazo si era el resultado de una
violación o incesto o si el feto
presentaba anomalías graves la nueva ley
establece que las mujeres pueden
interrumpir el embarazo dentro de los
tres primeros meses si es probable que
agrave o cause un malestar material
educativo profesional o moral
incompatible con el interés de la mujer
o del feto benin se une ahora a una
lista de un puñado de países africanos
que tienen leyes de aborto relativamente
liberales las autoridades sanitarias
afirman que las últimas medidas ayudarán
a muchas mujeres que se ven obligadas a
arriesgar su vida utilizando métodos de
aborto inseguros
impulso de fin
aquí desean el 20 por ciento de las
muertes de mujeres son consecuencia del
aborto clandestino y el 15 por ciento de
las muertes maternas entre las mujeres
en general es una causa del aborto
clandestino en total
la voz toma un clon de este a pesar de
que la enmienda ha sido aprobada el
debate en el parlamento de benin fue
acalorado puesto que muchos políticos
inicialmente se opusieron a la
legislación otros grupos religiosos
influyentes también se han manifestado
en contra de la ley que aún debe ser
ratificada por el tribunal
constitucional del país antes de que
entre en vigor